sírvase ver todo el video antes de
retirar su
catéter este video le enseñará Cómo
vaciar su bolsa de fi antes de retirar
el catéter de
Fly un catéter de Fly es un tubo de
jeeve delgado que va desde su vejiga
hasta la bolsa de Fly donde se recolecta
la orina un globo lleno de agua mantiene
el catéter en su lugar
con una jeringa se extrae el agua del
Globo A través del Puerto del
globo retirar el catéter de fouly
implica Vaciar la bolsa de
fouly desinflar El globo y extraer el
catéter usted necesitará guantes
desechables una jeringa para extraer el
agua del globo y un paño limpio o
toallas de papel para limpiarlos de
rames
asegúrese de mantener la bolsa de fi por
debajo del nivel de sus caderas para
permitir que la orina drene fuera de la
vejiga hacia la
bolsa paso uno lávese las manos con agua
y jabón y luego
séquel paso dos sostenga la parte
inferior de la bolsa de fouly sobre un
inodoro paso tres abra la válvula de
drenaje la orina empezará a drenar desde
la bolsa vacíe la orina de la
bolsa paso cuatro cierre la
válvula ahora empezará a retirar el
catéter paso cinco lávese nuevamente las
manos con agua y jabón y luego
séquel paso seis Póngase los guantes
desechables
paso siete suelte el catéter de su
[Música]
pierna paso ocho sostenga el tubo del
Puerto del Globo en una mano empuje
firmemente el extremo de la jeringa en
el puerto del globo y gire hasta lograr
una conexión
hermética el agua del globo empieza a
llenar la
jeringa paso nu cuando el globo vacío
Relájese respire profundamente y tire
suavemente del catéter para
[Música]
retirarlo no tire con fuerza si al tirar
suavemente no logra retirar el catéter
comuníquese con su proveedor de atención
médica después de retirar el catéter
tome abundante agua para crear la
necesidad de orinar y disminuir la de
ardor al paso de la
orina comuníquese con su cirujano Si
tiene alguna pregunta sobre su catéter
de fi su temperatura es de 38 gr celus
101 gr Fahrenheit o más siente la vejiga
llena pero no ve que la orina drene
hacia la bolsa de
fi no puede retirar el catéter tirando
suavemente de él su orina es turbia
tiene mal olor o nota una gran cantidad
de sangre en
ella
es normal ver una pequeña cantidad de
sangre en la orina luego de retirar el
catéter de
Fly además comuníquese con su cirujano
si no puede orinar dentro de las 8 horas
siguientes al retiro del catéter de fi
siente ardor o dolor al orinar que dura
más de 24
horas su abdomen se siente hinchado o
hay presencia de dolor en el área
perianal siente la necesidad de orinar
con más frecuencia de lo normal o no
siente su vejiga vacía al terminar de
[Música]
orinar